Come on.
It's time for another chapter
of my rags-to-riches life story.
Welcome to Acapulco.
Now, everyone, get to work.
Memo was finally working
at the pool with me.
Chad and Julia
made their engagement official.
But I was happy for them
because I had my eyes on someone new.
Maximo.
So, what's Maximo's deal?
I think he's Mexican.
I didn't know it yet,
but everything
was about to change for me.
Do you always
have to make things a mystery?
I don't know.
Do I?
Anyway...
A dark time in my life was approaching.
My family was at risk
of losing everything.
But sometimes things have to break apart
to come back stronger.
Life doesn't always take you
where you think you should go.
But it has a way of leading you
to where you should be.
Happiness is about
finding where you belong.
Will the owner
of the whitest ass in Mexico
please come to the front desk.
Who's messing with the PA?
Hey. Not funny.